The Witcher offers some clues as to its chronology
for fans who are paying close attention.
With work, you can piece more or less the
entire timeline together.
There are still some questions and ambiguities,
but the overall picture works just fine.
Here's what you need to know.
Viewers don't see the earliest scenes in The
Witcher until the season's final episode.
Through Geralt's flashbacks, we meet his biological
mother, Visenna, and watch as she abandons
Geralt at Kaer Morhen, where he meets his
mentor Vesemir and begins his witcher training.
In an interview, The Witcher showrunner Lauren
Schmidt Hissrich revealed that Geralt is already
100 years old by the time viewers meet him
in the first episode.
That means that young Geralt's scenes must've
happened at the very beginning of The Witcher
timeline.
Of The Witcher's three main timelines, Yennefer's
origin story comes first.
Yennefer looks fairly young when Tissaia buys
her from her father in episode two, and all
of Yennefer's early days happen before the
rest of the main plot.
We don't know how long Yennefer spends at
school, but it doesn't seem like much.
Hunchback Yennefer, who should age like a
normal human, doesn't show many physical changes
during her studies.
However, according to Hissrich, Yennefer's
story in season one spans about 70 years.
After ascending, Yennefer spends 30 years
in the court at Aedirn, and another 10 or
so kicking around as an independent sorceress
before the Battle of Sodden.
That leaves 30 years unaccounted for.
Either Hissrich had her numbers wrong, or
Yennefer trains at Aretuza for a lot longer
than it seems.
Geralt's first three adventures take place
next.
It's not clear exactly how long it takes Geralt
to become known as the Butcher of Blaviken
or how long it took Jaskier to make Geralt
famous.
Given that Geralt's entire story in season
one is about 20 years long, and that 12 years
pass between Geralt's two visits to Cintra,
an eight-year period between episode one and
episode four makes sense.
We can also surmise that Geralt's battle with
the striga in episode three takes place about
30 years after Yennefer's transformation.
At the sorceror's ball in Yennefer's timeline,
King Foltest of Temeria can be seen pestering
his sister Adda, and the future monarch looks
to be around 10 years old.
When Geralt meets him, Foltest is in his 40s,
and Adda has been dead for years.
Yennefer and Geralt's stories in episode four
seem to happen at around the same time.
Yennefer claims that she's been at Aedirn
for three decades before she decides to strike
out on her own, and that's about how much
time has passed for Foltest in Geralt's timeline
in episode three.
Further, Geralt's reputation is firmly established
by the time that he first enters Queen Calanthe's
court.
This is the first episode that makes it crystal
clear that we're following three separate
timelines.
In the episode, Nilfgaard is a joke, and Ciri's
mother is newly pregnant.
In the first episode, though, Calanthe and
Eist are married, Ciri is 12 years old, and
Nilfgaard is a mighty military force.
In "Bottled Appetites," the star-crossed lovers
Geralt and Yennefer meet for the very first
time, courtesy of a djinn in a bottle.
Enough time passes between "Bottled Appetites"
and "Rare Species" for Geralt and Yennefer
to build up quite a bit of history.
Their bickering references numerous encounters
beyond the one we've already seen, and they
seem to have spent quite a bit of time together.
Yennefer and Jaskier know each other pretty
well at this point, too, and they don't seem
to get along.
"witchers are bound to run into monsters
eventually."
"Jaskier."
"Yennefer."
"The crow's feet are new."
Cintra falls
Finally, Ciri's story begins brings the three
timelines together with the collapse of Cintra.
In the leadup to Nilfgaard's attack, Yennefer
joins the Brotherhood of Sorcerers to discuss
the impending invasion, while Geralt goes
directly to Cintra to try to rescue Ciri.
In fact, Geralt was in Cintra when Ciri fled
the city.
Unfortunately, Calanthe had locked him in
a dungeon to keep him from running off with
Ciri.
At any rate, Ciri's storyline in episode one
and Geralt and Yennefer's plots in episode
seven happen at the same time.
According to Hissrich, Ciri's story in The
Witcher's first season unfolds over the course
of a couple of weeks.
Ciri meets Dara shortly after escaping Cintra,
and only spends a little bit of time in the
refugee camp before Nilfgaard attacks.
A few days later, she enters Brokilon Forest.
After a few nights in Brokilon, the doppler,
disguised as Mousesack, takes Ciri and Dara
away.
Ciri discovers the deception and frees herself
soon afterwards.
From there, Ciri fends for herself.
She tries to pawn off her jewelry for cash,
and is ultimately offered a home by a kindly
woman with a house in the woods.
All of this unfolds in the time between Geralt's
second visit to Cintra in episode seven and
his arrival at the former refugee camp in
episode eight.
By the beginning of episode eight, "Much More,"
all three timelines are in sync.
While Yennefer and her fellow sorcerers are
fighting Nilfgaard at Sodden, Geralt is fighting
for his life on the back of a merchant's cart,
and Ciri is waiting in a cabin with the merchant's
wife.
All of this happens about a week after Ciri
fled the refugee camp.
When Geralt first meets the merchant, the
man is cleaning up the bodies the Nilfgaardian
army left behind.
The episode also takes place over a couple
of days.
The sorcerers arrive at Sodden and prep their
defenses in the daytime.
The ensuing battle begins at night, takes
the whole next day, and ends just before dawn.
The morning after the battle is when Geralt
and Ciri meet for the first time.
Yennefer disappears after using a ton of magic
to channel fire at the Nilfgaardian army,
but she's probably not gone for good.
As the season ends, Yennefer is the one everyone's
talking about.
"Who is Yennefer?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.